Okay, so now we're starting to get secondary
effects of Donald Trump's actions against
Iran, which Donald Trump is going to then
conveniently cite as the causes that justify
his own belligerent actions. This is circular
reasoning. This is really important to understand.
I'm going to try to explain it as clearly
as possible because this is of such importance.
Earlier in his presidency, you might remember
that Donald Trump abandoned the Iran nuclear
agreement. That nuclear agreement included
the United States and Iran as well as other
countries like France. Um, and what that agreement
did was it restricted what Iran was allowed
to do when it comes to nuclear research and
the enrichment of uranium, it mandated inspections
and did a number of other things. At the time
that Donald Trump said, we're out of the deal.
Iran had not violated the deal. They had stuck
to it. The deal had been signed under Obama.
Some people like the deal, some people didn't
like the deal, but most people, even if they
didn't like the deal, recognized that the
word of the United States matters geopolitically.
And if we get into an agreement and then the
next president, because he just doesn't like
it, says I'm out. We lose credibility as a
country and Donald Trump without Iran having
done anything wrong in terms of the deal,
said we're out the United States is out that
put Iran in a weird place.
The U S is out, but other countries are still
in it. But Trump's increasingly unhinged and
putting sanctions on as what do we do? Do
we go back to enriching uranium and researching
nuclear technology or don't we? In the middle
of this, the French president Emmanuel Macron
was trying to keep Iran compliant with the
deal to save it and then of course Donald
Trump had more tough talk for Iran and put
sanctions on Iran and last week Donald Trump
goes and assassinates Iranian codes leader
Kaseem Sola Mani and is now threatening to
attack Arabian cultural sites, which is a
war crime and I will talk about later. So
Iran does what we would expect them to do
at this point in time. They say, Hey guys,
we're out, right? We're no longer going to
abide by the 2015 nuclear deal that we stuck
to, but then Donald Trump canceled and then
sanctioned us and then assassinated one of
our military leaders and now is threatening
war crimes by the via the destruction of cultural
sites.
We're out and Iran will go back to enriching
uranium and this foments the pretext that
to war with Iran, the Trump administration
is now going to site Iran bailing on the deal
as a reason to go after them. These are going
to say, look, Iran is going crazy. Iran bailed
on the deal and now they're going to enrich
uranium. We've got to go after them. Well,
but hold on a second. You bailed on them when
they were in compliance and then you sanctioned
them and then you assassinated their leader
and then you threatened war crimes against
them. So they said, we are out. This is not
a defense of Iran from any kind of a policy
point of view. It's merely pointing out that
almost any country in Iran, his position would
do this because it would be the logical thing
to do. And now Trump can say we've got to
go after them because they bailed on the deal.
And clearly their intentions are subversive
and insidious. You cause them to bail. It's
your actions that made them take this course
of action. No, no, no. We've got to go after
them. They're belligerent. Look, now they're
not even sticking to the deal. Wait a second.
You got out of the deal a year ago or however
long it was. So what my goal here is you need
to be prepared for these talking points because
you are going to be propagandized to, you
are going to be disinfected armed about this.
They will cite effects of their own actions
as causes for their actions and causes justifying
military intervention and the Fox news audience
is mostly going to fall for it. Trump's lackeys
will be tweeting the talking points endlessly
because they are determined here. Donald Trump
is desperate to distract from impeachment.
He will use any reasoning no matter how uh,
a bogus, no, no matter how a flacid I know
I've mentioned that term a term a couple of
times today.
It's a good term to describe what, what is
going on. You are going to be the target of
this disinformation campaign. We are already
seeing it to a great extent. Tucker Carlson
took a little bit of a different view and
that's interesting and we're going to get
to that later. But this is it that they are
causing. Uh, they are, they are taking actions
that have effects and then citing the effects
in a vacuum as the causes for going into Iran.
For assassinating people on authorize despite
what Donald Trump said Barack Obama had to
do back during his presidency to take military
action. It's, it's feeling so much like the
lead up to the Iraq war. This is just one
element of it, and anytime that Iran bailing
on the deal is cited as a reason why we need
to take action, remember that we bailed first
for no reason.
Iran
was
in compliance.